i don't think people appreciate
uh
when i think of if i thought about going
back and just visiting saranac live and
going in there i think it would bring
back
it was a lot of fun but it was a lot of
pressure too right right and that comes
back when you go back to sarno live i
imagine when you first get there you go
back to being in your early 20s and
feeling like your whole career depends
on what i come up with this week right
which might take a couple of days to get
over you know you're right you bring it
on yourself but but i i these guys were
so nice to me the cast was so friendly
and i got to know each one very well and
became friends with her i really love
those guys now and the writers it was
just reminded me of when we were there
and how it was so important to try to do
your best and come up with a couple of
good kisses they were all so funny uh
and night and just nice people and and
lauren was great to me lauren kept
relaxing me and we talked and lauren
relaxed you that's i mean
that was not his role back in the day
right right his rule but not back in the
day was not like you look nervous relax
you'll be here as long as you want to
no that was not what he walked around
doing well we we he
he definitely made me feel like like he
you know i i'm 30 years older so we we
had a different relationship this time
and it was great he was nice to me and
uh just we talked about a million
different things and and lauren's an oh
he's older he's been doing it for so
long so anyways we had 104 years old
apparently
yeah he's
it was a
something that um
like
on the monday when it was over my god
was i i got hit like i was so tired back
back when we did it we could go three
weeks in a row and keep rocking and stay
up for two to stay up for two three days
in a row exactly me i would see uh conan
all night long on the tuesdays and uh he
was always conan and smigiel and smigiel
came and wrote that week robert
schmeichel yes he came and wrote that
week
he he uh
i i i ended up doing the opera man and
uh and i when i came
came to do it
people were saying what what are you
gonna bring back to the show when i was
i have no idea what i'm supposed to
bring back and uh so all week long we
didn't even think about it and then
friday
uh robert called me at me says i think
you have to do opera man i said i do he
goes let me just write up something so
him and a couple of my buddies wrote it
up and gave it to me and they they wrote
all the jokes that's fantastic
[Music]
[Applause]